this this hits hard a dream doesn't
become reality through magic Taylor
Swift anyone who's ever tried to achieve
something we no doing stuff is hard
starting a business learning a new
language getting in shape even if
something is Trivial or setting up a new
year's resolution you don't immediately
give up on after a week of making it
many of us have something we want to
achieve some far off goal we've had for
a while and here you are lying in bed at
2 a.m. getting recommended a video of
some inspirational going you
want to be an alpha like me it's easy I
wake up at 3:00 a.m. last month to get a
head start 4:00 a.m. make piss 5:00 a.m.
eject piss 6:00 a.m. drink piss which is
why if any of you have gone through this
before if any of you are in the process
of undertaking some big personal
projects you need to read beaten motion
this is a story about those who have a
dream and those who work hard to achieve
it but also how easy it can be to lose
your way stumbling across the infinite
roadblocks on that path giving up on it
and becoming bitter about other people
trying to accomplish what you couldn't
I've never read a story that hits so
close to home when a came to shooting
for a goal I set for myself and in the
process lit a fire under my ass not
forget why I set that goal in the first
place cuz maybe the only missing piece I
didn't have for getting to my dreams was
right there in front of me a cute anime
girl legging me on some dreams can be
big but some dreams can also be small
like having a nice meal and that dream
might not be so far away thanks to my
friends over at boxu today's sponsor
boxu is a premium Japanese snack box
that focuses on delivering authentic
Japanese treats all over the world they
work with family businesses from all
over Japan and deliver a new theme of
authentic treats every single month all
right weebs let me tell you how it works
the first month you sign up to boxu you
get this one the seasons of Japan it's
basically boxo's best hits of their best
treats that you can get all over the
year and then after the first month you
get a different themed box every single
month but first let's see what the first
box you get it's going to be like I
always get excited every time I get the
seasons of Japan box because I get to
eat the white strawberry Chocolat once
again they basically infused a real
Japanese strawberry with white chocolate
and it's honestly one of my favorite
snacks that I get to eat
M hits every single time but I'm going
to try a new snack this time as well
let's try the sui Samu anpan chocolates
I've never had a chocolate anpan before
so this should be interesting ooh look
at this oh I already know this is going
to
slap oh buxu is the perfect gift to give
to a friend for anyone who's been dying
to travel to Japan and try some of their
amazing food over here Japan has an
incredible snack culture and this is the
perfect time for a friend to experience
that so guys with Christmas coming up
this is the perfect gift to give someone
you care about so what are you waiting
for get your first box Su today by
clicking that link in the description
and using code gigar for $15 off your
first boxu purchase that's the code on
screen for $15 off guys thank you very
much to boxu for sponsoring me today
back to the video Dreams they're a
Fickle thing especially if they take off
the mask many of us have had our own
dreams and somewhere along the way we
may have given up on that dream maybe
you've gotten older and had that cynical
friend tell you to grow up cuz that
dream's never going to happen if that's
true just just remember these words bees
don't waste their time explaining to
Flies why honey is better than
[Music]
that was a real quote I saw on Tik
Tok about achieving your dreams but hey
maybe that guy was on to something honey
does indeed taste better than
probably now tell me are you a bee or a
fly huh tatso is a fly but he wasn't
always like that the only thing he ever
wanted to become as a kid was an
animator day in day out he would draw
show his parents improve his craft an
animator was what he was going to become
until one day when some bully showed his
work to a girl and she said the one
thing no boy ever wants to hear ew
cringe yeah I know even to this day
cringe takes the lives of thousands of
teenagers worldwide so he vowed never to
be cringe again and quit drawing his
dream Ended as quickly as it started
that is until he found a new passion a
new dream music he pours everything into
music his heart his soul he started a
band he started composing his own songs
he was painfully mediocre he didn't have
the spark he didn't have the talent and
over time crashes back down to reality
classic fly Behavior over time he
realized average people don't achieve
their dreams it's dumb to even have
dreams let's just start on
everyone around me who has a stupid
dream they want to shoot for what a
loser you know the thing about guys like
you I hate their
guts This is Nico a cool spunky
emotional girl and certified fly hater
the type of person who isn't going to
let some down loser on other
people's dreams even if it means briefly
making it seem like she pushed that
loser into an oncoming vehicle Jesus all
right that's a bit excessive so tat
heiko does what any man would do after
confronting a near-death experience with
a truck in a cool anime girl get
inspired isai fans be like he questions
how that bright optimistic kid turned
into such a sad Twisted adult he starts
trolling through years of his old
animation and you know what they weren't
bad they were decent and most
importantly he had fun doing them why
did he ever give up on this dream in the
first place maybe he was just
approaching it wrong maybe it wasn't
just a waste of time maybe he could
actually do it and before he knew it a
flame had been lit up again he spends
the next 3 months animating a fan-made
music video of his favorite Indie singer
it's tough work it didn't turn out
perfect but he felt a satisfaction he
thought he couldn't feel anymore and at
the end of that tunnel there was someone
there someone who had been waiting years
to see him again he was that inner child
bursting with Vigor and enthusiasm he
thought was long gone lost in the
cynical road to adulthood when in
reality he was right there waiting for
that young spark of passion to be
reignited that was chapter 1 Dreamcast
Cadbury's Minecraft if you couldn't tell
this is a manga about dreams what does
it mean to shoot for a dream how easy it
is to get lost on the way of achieving
it the importance of having one in the
first place beaten motion is a manga
that immediately connected with that
side of me that wanted to go out and
Achieve something that feeling you get
when you make the commitment to
undertake a massive life project this is
a story about us art and artists and the
struggles that goes into being creative
but really it hits an emotional core I
think almost anyone can relate to
everyone everyone I know has an ambition
even if that ambition is just trying to
find an ambition in the first place and
this is a bitingly real look at what
that Journey looks like not just for
tatah heiko niik it turns out is the
Indie singer he was a fan of and Drew an
animated video for and even though she's
clearly more outspoken about people who
put down other people's dreams that
doesn't mean she doesn't get anxiety
about achieving her own she wants to be
a famous singer songwriter the path for
anyone getting to their goals can be far
more arduous than we ever imagined when
we set out on that Journey sometimes all
it takes is the right person to say the
right thing at the right time to ignite
your passion for something but sadly
what I feel we see more often is the
wrong person saying the wrong thing at
the wrong time that completely
extinguishes that passion and beaten
motion is chock full of moments on both
sides of that Spectrum you see without
being overly optimistic or cynical with
the reality of what it's like to chase a
dream one scene that stood out for me
was when a famous director was giving
advice to a bunch of school kids if you
have a dream he said imagine yourself in
5 years then 10 years fully visualize a
path to that dream of yours then write
it down and look at it from time to time
and some kids like that's it that's all
we need to do and he's like nope but no
dream will come true if you can't
imagine it first now that's some be talk
right there to many of us dreams remain
just that dreams something intangible
Something Out Of Reach and sometimes
there's a certain comfort in that when
there's a goal so beyond your grasp you
can fantasize about it imagine yourself
in that position and it feels good
there's no pressure for you to go out
and do it cuz you can never imagine
yourself getting there in the first
place but once you actually take the
steps to visualize your path to that
goal that's what separates the dreamers
from the Believers the bees from the
Flies you're not just a boy with a dream
anymore you're a man with a plan and if
we can collectively all do that then
together we will be men with
plan yeah that makes sense but this is
when it starts getting scary it's not
just some far off idea it actually seems
t tangible and what's terrifying isn't
the thought of not achieving your dreams
it's the thought of trying and failing
along the way this is a fear every
character in the story is constantly
struggling with not me though I don't
have that issue cuz you know Mama didn't
raise no quitter and you can't quit
something if you never started anything
in the first place early on Nico and
tatso have a shared dream of working on
a big project together she'd write and
sing the song and he'd animate the music
video she makes the Beats he makes the
Motions eh get it h h they meet up
discuss IDE Scout location storyboard
scenes they were making progress they
were taking all the right steps oh
what's this out of nowhere Nico gets kna
to be signed by a massive record label
the project has to be put on indefinite
hold but that's fine you know cuz at
least one of them gets to have their
dream come to fruition this is great
news that project can just wait for
another time for now let's just be happy
that one of them gets to take a big step
towards their dreams oh what the day she
was getting signed the higher ups of the
record label decide to stop debuting all
new artists due to budget issues for how
long for an undetermined amount of
time I've never seen a story so
accurately portray that unpredictable
Journey you can take when trying to
achieve something you may have this all
mapped out in your head you start at
Point a and your destination is at point
B that's where your goals lie simple but
then due to unforeseen circumstances it
means you have to have a pit stop at C
first then D then e then F then G and
before you know it your map looks like
this you're completely lost you don't
even know where you are where your
Destin is or even why you started the
journey in the first place it's a Shonen
battle Series where the end game is your
dream and your opponent is life and let
me tell you woo life pretty damn op the
series has its way of doing things that
really makes it feel like it hits close
to home this is the debut manga of Nai
fuga but You' think that they'd be a
veteran that's been in the industry for
years with the way he lays out these
panels that sometimes feels a little too
real even if it's just some small moment
that doesn't have any bearing to the
larger plots there's a scene where tatso
is just Reminiscing on how he got this
passion in the first place and the manga
takes us back to when he was a kid
standing at the beach when you're in
school you're bombarded with different
stimuli that come crashing at you and as
he looks down he sees different pieces
of paper math PE English movies he
happened to pick up the fragment the
said anime other kids picked up
different fragments and he walked away
leaving the other fragments behind and
seeing this even though I'd never heard
anyone describe it this way I was like
damn I get that the manga has his way of
conveying thoughts and imagy that seems
so intimate you can almost feel the
author's own life experience bleed
across every page this doesn't just feel
like a fictional story this feels like
someone's deepest emotions hopes and
anxieties edged onto the page some lines
of dialogue feel so biting I almost feel
like I'm intruding in a therapy session
hearing all the lines the manga ever
received on his own Journey characters
will say a piece that cuts so deeply it
almost feels a bit to on the nose and
I'm sitting here thinking man are you
good is there anything you want to get
off your chest but it's moments like
these that give the story its weight
this is a series that exudes genuine
human emotion from from every single
page it's the type of story you can find
something to learn from without it ever
being too preachy I honestly feel like
anyone who has a goal in life or even
those who are lost and perhaps searching
for one will find a moment that really
hits close to home to something you've
gone through or are dealing with I know
I found myself losing hope of achieving
my goals before I've wanted something
and worked my ass off to get there but
somewhere along the road I'd lost touch
with the motivation I had when I started
it but sometimes you get that moment
where you feel that spark being relit
and those are the moments that stick
with you those Sparks are the safe point
on the journey to making your dream come
true and it's those little moments I
think that is what beaten motion is all
about this is a series that shows you
every side of that long arduous Road
anyone takes when achieving something it
doesn't sugarcoat anything but it
doesn't undermine the value of smaller
more intimate goals no matter how
trivial or meaningless those goals may
seem to other people are you enjoying
the weather there yeah I'm enjoying it
yeah but you're in the bin it calls
people out for judging others on their
dreams and makes it clear that all
dreams no matter how big or small are
valid and important to those who work
hard to achieve them listen noed if I
want to have a a swim in my own bin on
the hottest day that we've ever had in
England then I'm entitled to do so and
while calling those people out teaches
you to own up on your own harsh
criticisms of others all right sorry
yeah you should be sorry off you toddle
but with that all said it Still Remains
grounded and keeps you keenly aware that
you need to be realistic most dreams
don't come
true I guess what I'm trying to say with
all this is I'm actually a
[Music]
fly hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to author
Curtis X basil dysfunctional degenerate
flabber husbando Hub Mike 808 misaka
12315 pain patchet Pony Stark shouting
zombie water gist VT and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible I don't know how it's happened
guys but uh it's December again and you
know what that means it's time to catch
up with all the anime I've missed over
the course of the year that I might have
wanted to watch yes I am going to be
starting production my best of anime
2023 so that's going to be coming out in
January so in December I'll just say
right now you guys can expect one more
video because I do want a Christmas
holiday this year but anyway hope you
guys get your Christmas shopping done
okay if you celebrate Christmas I've
been gig and I'll see you all next time